they are called super predators no
conscience no empathy last time I
actually drove a car myself was 1996
okay I can't drive anymore
I am running hello hello are you running
we have a problem those people are
trying to kill us this is really scary
they make Saddam Hussein look like a
choirboy I call the basket of deplorable
they're calling them all sorts of great
names they are called super predator
excuse me I'll use the word anchor
babies I will build the greatest wall
looking back it would have been better
for me to use two separate phones I will
make that wall in penetrable okay
impenetrable and if you actually will
even look great I already know what it
should look like we don't want to build
walls we want to build bridges I think
she's crazy I think she's crazy we have
no idea who these people are Bing well
that hurts my feelings she just fainted
I assume that was Devon you also
said okay I don't know what it is maybe
she's lazy I will take care of women I
respect women I will grab butter pudding
something's going on and it's not good I
have a feeling and maybe Obama's fault I
don't feel no ways tired let's see what
happens that has been tried that has
failed you gotta pay your bills I have a
feeling that by the end of this evening
I'm gonna be blamed for everything
that's ever gonna use some tic-tacs just
in case they start kissing her thank God
we have guns in case these guys broke
into the house and I'm a big Second
Amendment person there is a
constitutional right for people to own
guns but there's also a constitutional
right to life liberty and extreme what
kind of person believes that oppressed
is very dishonest okay and by the way I
think their ratings are gonna go down
really sharply now now you tell me those
those things can't get through this
lousy pile of wood impenetrable I don't
buy that i buy it his wife and kids
downstairs I think the American Dream is
big enough for everybody
why not come in come on in we're stupid
we'll take care of you look we have a
lot of really bad dudes outside it's far
worse than anybody in this room
understands far worse they're not
supposed to be doing them you have to go
back I'm a nice person believe it or not
I mean I have a heart but you have to go
back mortally wounded I respect anyone
who when they're knocked down gets back
up they're taunting us okay they're
playing games with
bye-bye that's us he was seriously hot
is it working
they're pretty much all gone okay pretty
much this is just a miserable way to
spend a Sunday
okay the generals aren't doing so well
right now a little dark you feel safe
right now I don't feel so safe
get them out of here now get him out get
him out try getting it out try getting
it out go ahead cut it out she doesn't
have a chance
I believe Hilary's leaving I like people
that weren't captured okay I hate to
tell you don't worry about that baby I
love babies actually I was only kidding
you can get the baby out of here you
know you could see there was blood
coming out of her eyes blood coming out
of her wherever childcare is such a big
problem what a stiff more energy tonight
I like that you're fired
oh yeah yeah this is not easy stuff
we'll do something let me go to sleep
first unbelievable people are coming and
they have guns
and they should people go check out the
house there's something there I heard a
noise these are very very good people
and they are protecting the Second
Amendment right man hit him in the head
right between the eyes
we're gonna take back our country and
we're gonna make American I will sue